[Musica]
sin da piccola ho imparato che i miei
desideri potevano essere una fonte di
disturbo per le persone intorno a me che
qui andavano contenuti sono sempre stata
una bambina piuttosto tranquilla
le frasi che hanno descritto i miei
primi anni di vita sono state mangia e
dorme e dove la metti sta sempre
pronunciate come una certa ammirazione
praticamente di me veniva apprezzata
soprattutto l'assenza
ho capito subito che esistevano desideri
accettabili e altri che non lo erano e
che per quest'anno onore pressi i primi
desideri ovviamente dovranno passare al
vaglio dei miei genitori e quindi sapevo
che al bar potevo desiderare al massimo
il gelato piccolo cornetto basi magnum
no
i giochi li potevo desiderare solo a
natale e al compleanno e dovevano essere
molto educativi e poco costosi giochi di
società si costruzioni di invocare
bambole meglio di no futili ma la cosa
migliore che potessi fare era desiderare
in silenzio non chiedere mai niente e
accontentarmi sempre di quello che
arrivava perché era un po come non
desidera da fatto
siccome non volevo rovinare l'immagine
di brava figlia che mi avevano cucito
addosso iniziato a silenziare i miei
desideri
fino a quando quelli delle altre persone
si sono sovrapposte i miei prima quelli
dei miei genitori poi quelle di maestre
e professori quelli delle medie mi
avevano detto che avrei potuto
desiderare al massimo un istituto
tecnico nel mio futuro
crescendo anche mib is very dovranno
crescere e allinearsi alle aspettative
sociali quindi avrei dovuto desiderare
prima di andare bene a scuola poi di
coltivare delle buone amicizie di
trovare un buon lavoro e infine un bravo
ragazzo con il quale sistemarmi e
costruire una famiglia di sani principi
tutti quei desideri che ti posizionano
correttamente all'interno della società
insomma che tengono al riparo dal
giudizio
quante volte i desideri socialmente
accettabili si sovrappongono ai nostri
in un ipotetica gerarchia di desideri
quelli più inconfessabili meno
accettabili più giudicati sono i
desideri sessuali
i desideri sessuali sono qualcosa di
viscerale che radicata in profondità
dentro ogni individuo e per questo sono
personali e unici possano essere
condizionati dall esterno certo ma
nascono dall interno e sfuggono a
qualsiasi regola e codice etico possono
andare contro i nostri stessi valori e i
principi morali contro il nostro ruolo
sociale possiamo essere un autoritario
dirigente d'azienda e desiderare il
momento in cui potremo finalmente
barattare i nostri abiti formali camicia
cravatta mocassini con dei collant dei
tacchi un grembiule e vestire i panni di
un assist ima ed una domestica servile e
sottomessa alla sua mistress desiderio
di femminilizzazione
spesso proviamo paura per i nostri
desideri perché temiamo che possano
rivelare chi siamo per davvero che
possano sbagliare il mostro che teniamo
nascosto dentro quando invece descrivono
che cosa vogliamo cosa ci attira in un
certo ambito della vita quello sessuale
in questo caso
ma perché quello che desideriamo
sessualmente dovrebbe determinare che
tipo di persona di professionista di
genitore di figlia di cittadino siamo e
che decide cosa è giusto cosa
accettabile e cosa invece è perverso
immorale e degradante
ed è possibile che qualcosa che viene
socialmente considerato degradante se
anche soggettivamente eccitante e
divertente
per quanto ci sembri una dimensione
sempre più lontana da noi la religione
condizione ancora molto il nostro
piacere secondo le ultime statistiche
circa il 75 per cento della popolazione
si definisce cristiano e cattolico
parliamo di tre persone su quattro più o
meno più di 40 milioni di persone
ti è piaciuto questo tipo di educazione
ha imparato che non sono solo le nostre
azioni a essere condannabili ma anche i
pensieri possiamo peccare infatti in
pensieri parole opere e omissioni quindi
anche attraverso i desideri infatti due
dei dieci comandamenti disciplinano
proprio il desiderio non desiderare la
donna d'altri non desiderare la roba
d'altri
e questo mi porta a un'altra riflessione
quali sono i soggetti che nella nostra
società sono autorizzati a desidera a
desiderare il nono comandamento parla di
uomini che desiderano
non possiamo parlare di desiderio
sessuale senza parlare di genere perché
la nostra visione della sessualità è
ancora fortemente binaria e che dalle
persone di schierarsi ed identificarsi
nel genere di uomo o di donna e di
prendere parte a ruoli e destini
sessuali distinti opposti all uomo
attribuiamo un ruolo attivo di soggetto
desiderante l'uomo incoraggiata
impugnare il desiderio in ogni ambito
della vita compreso quello sessuale
un uomo che desidera è ambizioso e
virile il sesso è un territorio di
conquista per l'uomo un avvincente
battuta di caccia stato hanno al
contrario è relegata un lavoro passivo
ma non può essere soggetto desiderante
ma è l'oggetto del desiderio e quindi
vietata reprimere i propri desideri
una donna che desidera liberamente che
diventa soggetto sessuale attivo ha
sempre qualcosa da perdere la verginità
la dignità l'innocenza la purezza
perfino l'elasticità vaginale qui non si
capisce come che facendo molto sesso una
pagina dovrebbe dilatarsi mal pene non
si restringe mai
oltre eroi di genere abbiamo un altro
problema
viviamo permeati di una cultura negativa
della sessualità
tanto per cominciare abbiamo una
concezione molto limitata che cosa sia
al sesso chiamiamo stesso un numero
ristretto di cose e quasi tutte hanno a
che fare con il fallo un suo surrogato e
con l'atto della penetrazione
ma quante persone taglia fuori questa
visione quanti desideri invalida per
esempio quelli di chi non ha interesse
ad avere a che fare con un pene magari
per via dell'orientamento sessuale
quelli di chi non prova piacere
attraverso la penetrazione preferisce
fare altro di chi addirittura prova
dolore o ha problemi di erezione
la nostra immagine mentale del sesso
coinvolge almeno due persone però è un
po come dire che i nostri corpi da soli
non possono essere corpi sessuali non
possono sperimentare il piacere
basta questo a reprimere il desiderio di
auto esplorarsi e a confinare l'atto
della masturbazione in alcune fasi e ben
delimitate della vita quella delle
scienziate per esempio in cui abbiamo la
scusante di una la società immatura
quello in cui non abbiamo partner e
quindi ci possiamo accontentare di noi
c'è alcun limite di età anche parliamo
mai di persone anziane che si masturbano
sembra che raggiunto una certa soglia
smettiamo di essere persone desideranti
le uniche informazioni che riceviamo sul
sesso provenienza are a viverla
riguardano quelli che possiamo chiamare
gli effetti collaterali negativi
infezioni malattie sessualmente
trasmesse e gravidanze indesiderate
non esiste un educazione al piacere sano
consapevole e auto determinato
questa concezione negativa ce la
portiamo avanti per tutto il corso della
vita possiamo anche essere le persone
sessualmente più liberate ma il modo in
cui parliamo di sesso tradisce l'idea
che sia qualcosa di intrinsecamente
sporco che possa contaminare le persone
sentimenti puri poniamo il sesso in
antitesi con l'amore che invece sempre
una forza positiva l'amore unisce le
persone arricchendole mentre il sesso le
unisce ma togliendo qualcosa ci
esprimiamo con frasi come è stato solo
sesso come se stesso senza un trasporto
sentimentale non richiedesse un
investimento umano energetico e motivo
oppure niente sesso prima al primo
appuntamento
se non vogliamo sembrare delle persone
facili e superficiali
se vogliamo dimostrare che teniamo
all'altra persone che non vogliamo
sporcare un possibile sentimento
nascente col del sesso il sesso rovina
l'amicizia è invece il sesso non
potrebbe essere uno dei tanti modi
costruttivi e non distruttivi che
abbiamo per conoscerci e per
relazionarci con le altre persone
perché il modo in cui desideriamo non
potrebbe essere una parte esplicitata
del nostro racconto personale così come
lo sono per esempio quello che mangiamo
e quello che indossiamo
piacere sono morena mi piacciono i jeans
a zampa la pizza e ricevere stesso raul
e
il mio personale rapporto con la
sessualità e con i desideri è stato
condizionato per lungo tempo da questa
visione negativa dal senso di colpa
dalla vergogna dalla norma sessuale che
mi voleva morigerata eterosessuale è
monogama
quella norma che percepivo nel occhiate
torve di mio nonno quando mi guardava
mentre mi toccavo parti del corpo che
non avrei dovuto toccare o così pensavo
oppure nei discorsi delle mie amiche che
si mostrano oltraggiate di fronte alla
richiesta dei rispettivi fidanzati di
praticarli sesso orale ritenuto una
pratica per professioniste del sesso
detto in maniera molto più giudicante di
così
fino a quando qualcosa è cambiato e vi
sia aperta una nuova prospettiva sulla
sessualità
allora era impegnata in una relazione
monogama ed esclusiva che era felice e
piena d'amore e durava da oltre otto
anni il mio compagno di vita stavamo
bene insieme ma ci sembrava di aver
vissuto tutto quello che di intenso
c'era da vivere soprattutto da un punto
di vista sessuale sembrava che non
rimanesse altro che proseguire sulle
tappe successive della scala mobile
razionale e quindi unirci matrimonio
fare dei figli cresce la nostra famiglia
invecchiare insieme
intanto accontentarci di una vita
sessuale destinata a ridursi ea lasciare
il posto ad altre priorità
quella prospettiva per accendeva stretta
ci sembrava in qualche modo di sprecare
tutto l'amore che avevamo coltivato fino
a quel momento e non volevamo ridurci a
essere una coppia è esausta e rassegnata
allora ci siamo guardati dentro poi ci
siamo guardati negli occhi e ci siamo
aperti l'un l'altro fino in fondo è ben
capito che in realtà c'era un'altra
possibilità che avremmo dovuto smetterla
di realizzarci reciprocamente e lasciar
cadere le ultime maschere delle quali ci
vestivamo per trasmettere all'altra
persona un immagine è sufficientemente
accettabile di noi a quel punto la
sessualità è diventata il nostro spazio
di libertà all'interno del quale
sbrigliare tutti i nostri desideri e
mostri più nascosti e accogliere quelli
dell'altro abbandonando ogni forma di
giudizio per andare insieme alla ricerca
del piacere
tutti quei desideri che ho silenziato
che avevo messo da parte improvvisamente
erano diventati importanti per qualcuno
che non solo voleva ascoltarli ma anche
trasformarli in piacere
la sessualità è diventata anche un
argomento centrale nelle nostre vite
una materia di confronto quotidiano ma
parallelamente ci siamo resi conto di
quanto le altre persone facessero
davvero fatica a parlarne in modo
naturale è libero al di là soprattutto
dell'est avete battuto eguagliati che si
fermano la parte performativa
prestazioni durata frequenza dimensioni
ci siamo resi conto che nessuna persona
è abituato a parlare di sessualità
perché nessuna persona è stata educata a
farlo non possediamo un vocabolario del
piacere e non esiste ancora una cultura
positiva e condivisa della sessualità
così abbiamo deciso di provare a
costruirne una abbiamo creato le sex
rosa che un blog che parla di ricerca
del piacere come punto cardine vita
sessuale sana e appagante
io ho cominciato a divulgare un
messaggio sex positivo a incoraggiare le
persone a prendersi cura di questa
dimensione della vita ea compiere un
percorso di liberazione
diventare persone sessualmente liberate
però non significa obbligarsi a godere
del sesso
ma interrogarsi attivamente sullo spazio
che si occupa in ogni fase della nostra
vita sul significato che ha per noi
perché stesso non dovrebbe essere usato
come parametro per calcolare il valore
morale e sociale di una persona ma non
dovrebbe neanche essere dato per
scontato in una relazione o peggio
essere considerato dovuto
liberarsi significa abbracciare i propri
desideri e assumersi la piena
consapevolezza e responsabilità del
proprio piacere
da sex positivity ci educa anche alla
complessità e alla diversità perché non
può esistere un unico modo di essere
soggetti sessuali
l'esperienza sessuale deve rimanere
personale fluida mutevole non può essere
forzata a seguire una norma rigido e
prescrittiva e il peso della norma è
talmente ingombrante nelle nostre vite
che la maggior parte delle domande di
dubbi che hanno a che fare con la sfera
sessuale iniziano com è normale
e normale che non riesca a raggiungere
l'orgasmo senza stimolare la territorio
e normale che ami alla follia la mia
fidanzata ma che il sesso non mi
interessi
e normale che voglia essere penetrato
analmente con un dildo strappando a mia
moglie anche se sono etero
nel mio personale percorso di
liberazione
ho imparato anche a decostruire il
concetto di trasgressione che avevo
sempre letto in un'accezione negativa la
trasgressione sessuale è di solito
associata a pratiche particolarmente
libertine estreme che però giudichiamo
perverse ed esagerate trasgredire
significa rompere uno schema non
rispettare una norma
ma perché dovrebbe essere qualcosa è
necessariamente negativo di
inaccettabile di ragionevole quando è la
norma ad essere inaccettabile e
irragionevole quando la norma ci vuole
imporre uno dello sessuale che
stabilisce se possiamo desiderare cosa
possiamo desiderare e chi possiamo
desiderare
la sex positivi ci la sex positivity
celebrati di tutte queste norme e
riposiziona l'asticella
dell'accettabilità che non usciva più
tra normale perverso morale e immorale
ma tra consensuale e non consensuale
consapevole e non consapevole rispettoso
e discriminatorio una volta eliminata la
norma possiamo rimettere la persona al
centro della sessualità silenziare il
rumore di fondo delle aspettative
sociali del giudizio morale e restituire
voce al desiderio
possiamo e dobbiamo rivendicare il
diritto al piacere di tutti i costi
non so di quelli canonicamente
desiderabili quelli giovani quelli
perfettamente funzionanti ma anche
quelli non conformi quelli grassi quelli
vecchi quelli malati e quelli poco abili
che darà la possibilità a ogni persona
di decidere se e quando essere oggetto e
soggetto del desiderio
da quando ho iniziato divulgare questi
concetti le sette note è diventata anche
una community che ha preso le sembianze
un po di un grande condominio virtuale
in cui si parla liberamente di
sessualità e si condividono racconti
personali
in questi anni ho ascoltato le storie
delle vite sessuali più diverse storie
di grande liberazione e storia di grande
repressione
storie di donne che hanno conosciuto il
dolore del parto prima del piacere di un
orgasmo
ho visto quanto sia importante
recuperare una dimensione sociale la
sessualità
quanto sia importante abbattere il muro
di silenzio che regga il sesso è un
fatto privato è segreto e creare spazi
di confronto sia online che offline
la condivisione dei propri desideri
delle fantasie ma anche delle sicurezze
delle paure dei dubbi degli errori può
realmente contribuire al senso di
comunità e far sentire le persone meno
sole meno strane meno sbagliate
ho imparato che si può stare seduti
dietro uno schermo o dietro un tavolino
di un bar e parlare liberamente
dell'andamento dei propri orgasmi come
si fa la delle fluttuazioni dell'umore
che si può intavolare una conversazione
informale sulla simulazione anale con
chiunque sia presente perché tanto
l'anno e in tutti i corpi ed accesso un
piacere universale democratico e si può
chiedere una persona sabbia dei
feticismi così come le chiediamo se
abbia dei tatuaggi e intanto possiamo
sfornare le persone a cui vogliamo bene
a coltivare a ricercare la soddisfazione
sessuale nello stesso modo in cui le
motivo eseguire quella professionale
relazionale economica
in una società normata come la nostra in
cui l'eterosessualità e la monogamia
sono ancora le uniche forme di
sessualità e di relazione che sono
considerate ideali normali e accettabili
desiderare è un atto rivoluzionario
ma in fondo che cosa rimane di noi della
nostra essenza della nostra unicità
della nostra personalità
se rinunciamo alla parte viscerale
spontanea creativa i nostri desideri
sono la bussola del nostro piacere e ci
possono traghettare verso uno stato di
appagamento e di benessere globale
quindi oggi mi vito compiere questo atto
rivoluzionario
ad appropriarsi del vostro diritto al
piacere dei vostri corpi delle vostre
pulsioni del dei vostri desideri con il
consenso e nel rispetto di tutte le
persone che si uniranno alla vostra
esplorazione buona ricerca del piacere
[Musica]
[Applauso]